the upcoming holiday is one of the
busiest times of the years for animal
shelters because many pets tend to run
away from their homes during the
fireworks celebrations but this year
several shelters say they are worried
because they have no extra room
cats of all shapes and sizes no doubt
the summer season is a busy time for the
animal foundation the season also
putting a strain on their capacity we
have a little over 700 animals on campus
about 300 of those animals are available
for adoption right now kelsey peasy with
the animal foundation says the fourth of
july holiday is a busy time for her
staff because many pets get scared from
the fireworks last year
559 animals were dropped off between
july 1st and the 10th we were busy in
the during the pandemic but because of
the current economic crisis
we have never been busier and it's not
just our shelter it's shelters
everywhere if your pet runs away or you
find a lost animal local shelters
recommend using social media tools like
facebook or next door nevada spca 65 are
intake are owner-surrendered animals the
rest of it are transfers from other
shelters and we are full right now
and that's why it's so important if you
have financial resources right now to
give a home to a homeless pet
as the holiday rolls in double check
your home and your yard for any areas
your pet could escape from also be
creative pc says during the loud
celebrations
the best thing you can do as a pet owner
is create a safe and calm space in your
home
a crate would be best but you can use a
closet or a bathroom as long as there
aren't a lot of windows turn on the tv a
music a fan
well according to the animal foundation
only 20 percent of stray animals are
reconnected with their family so make
sure your pet is microchipped a tag and
all that information is updated all
these obviously have everything current
because that's where some of the
confusion might be yeah good information
right there